what kind of messed up it's official
are you what the hell
[Music]
mother's day is almost here y'all so
it's definitely one of our favorite
holidays to celebrate on this show but
let's be real
even the most well-intentioned mamas
will eventually make mistakes
not me but i've heard that some people
do so we asked you to send in your most
hilarious and unforgettable rather bad
mom moments and i'm going to read them
aloud for the entire world to hear
i am still ready for this okay my
husband was out of town and i was home
with my three young children
it had been a long day and as i was
making dinner they were all calling to
me
mom look at this mommy this doesn't work
etc got over there
i finally been here too i finally blew
up and he held
nobody is to say mom mommy or mama for
the next 10 minutes
a few minutes later my five-year-old
came into the kitchen and in his
sweetest voice said
excuse me kristin
my five-year-old boy is funny too excuse
me kristen
um
my kids wanted to go to chuck e cheese
yeah oh and i'm not a fan well what's
wrong with you
first of all who doesn't like chuck e
cheese oh when i drove by it it was
packed so i told them that chucky
died they asked how and i said by a
large
rat trap they asked why there were a lot
of cars there when we drove by and i
said it was
for chucky's funeral
what kind of messed up individual are
you
oh my god i mean i've said oh it's
closed today like things are closed like
can we go
starbucks i'm like it's closed today
sorry like i've totally said that but i
didn't say every employee
died there so you're never getting
coffee with starbucks again
jeez that's hardcore angela
oh like wow i don't know if anything's
gonna beat that one angela
who don't like chuck e cheese come on
because chucky died
what's she gonna do when a birthday
party happens and it happens to be there
oh he's lazarus he has risen
he came back but she'll say it's like
his cousin or something
when my son was young i was teaching
first graders all day
i would come home dead tired yet he was
always raring to go
one night i just couldn't do it so i set
the clock to show his bedtime i think i
know where she's going with this and
i've done this
um his bedtime which is eight even
though it was really 6
30 i told him to check the clock and he
came back and said
good night mom i love you we said our
prayers read an abbreviated story
and hit the hay score you know what if
you are a parent out there and saying
that you've never done this
congratulations you're a liar because
everyone has fibbed that it's a little
earlier so everyone's done that one
you're not as bad as angela chuck e
cheese murderer
our fish had babies and we separated
them until i thought they were big
enough to be put back into the
where this main tank their mother
promptly ate them
and choked on one they all died
including the mother my four-year-old
asked why the mother fish ate her babies
and i told her
it was because they were they weren't
listening
these moms i'm feeling good about myself
right now
that i knew the fish was gonna i knew
that was gonna happen my six-year-old
daughter and i were on our way to town
and a car cut me off and almost caused
an accident i flipped him off
and when he pulled up next to him oh we
pulled up next to him at a stoplight i
looked over and it was santa claus
do you take your kids to see santa i do
and we've had pictures of
good moments and bad moments like yeah
they've been excited and then
last night oh my god actually last night
my kids for whatever reason really
wanted to know what i look like as a kid
and so i was like i'm sure there's like
a couple pictures online i didn't have
any like just on me at my house i was
like googled myself as a kid
literally i was like never done this but
i googled
like kelly clarkson as a kid or whatever
and
and and it came up like somebody did
some kind of collage thank you because
it was helpful
but anyway and i showed my kids and it
was so cute because they were like
remy was like oh that looks like me and
it was like me with like really short
blonde blonde hair and
then my daughter was like oh that one
looks like me and i do look like both of
them
at certain points and and one of them
i'm sitting with santa claus
and my my son my five-year-old just
freaked
out he is like you know him
that is so cool and like just freaked
out
and was like that is i was out of all
the things i've done in my life nothing
has been cooler than that picture to him
all right everybody we'll tune into the
show for a full rad mom hour and you're
gonna hear
lots of hilarious stories i promise well
and if you don't think they're funny
we have wasted your time you're welcome
want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure